You've said that a marriage must be
based on trust and transparency and
being shackled together.
How and for how long should you get to
know someone?
How does set a foundation?
Oh,
well,
you know,
there's no,
there's no simple answer to that.
Um,
hello.
I think that you should know someone
well enough so that you can so that you
know if you can negotiate with them and
so that you have started to formulate a
vision of your joint future that you can
both look forward to with enthusiasm and
confidence.
So,
and of course that's going to depend to
some degree on your level of maturity,
but that means you've considered such
things as do you have a sufficient
number of joint interests and are you
oriented in the same direction with
regards to how you're going to handle
your joint careers and the possibility
of children and that the manner in which
you're going to interact with your in
laws and you have to start thinking
about.
You have to start
considering your life together from the
perspective of practicality and
economics,
I would say,
so.
It can't just be that massive erotic
attraction that's associated with with
love,
although I think that's extraordinarily
important and you're unbelievably
fortunate if you have that and you
should do everything you can to maintain
it,
which and that takes effort.
That takes real effort at will,
but you need to ally that with with
maturity and intelligence and maturity
and intelligence is okay,
we're gonna,
put our lives together.
What's that going to look like at the
level of detail?
How are we going to handle our finances?
Where are we going to live?
What are our joint plans going to be?
It's et cetera.
One of the things that my business
partners and I plan to do in,
in,
what would you say that in as an analog
to the self authoring suite is that we
want to develop an online program to
help people negotiate their
relationships and and so it would
actually provide an answer to this
question in a more comprehensive manner,
is that imagine that if you want to set
up a household with someone,
then there's a lot of things that you
need to get straight and you either do
that by bringing your unconscious
assumptions to bear on the situation and
perhaps clashing where they don't match
or you sit down like a conscious and
aware and articulate couple and start to
negotiate what your joint
responsibilities are going to be.
And so that would be well,
um,
who's responsible for the meals and when
and what are you going to eat and who's
going to get groceries and who's going
to pay the bills and who's going to do
which part of what household chores
there are to do.
And how is that going to be laid out?
Fair.
And so you should get to know,
you should get to know the person that
you're with well enough so that you can
start discussing the real practical
issues of life and determine whether or
not you're capable of of negotiating
that.
And I don't think that necessarily means
that you should live together because
the evidence is actually quite strong.
At least the last time I looked at
people who live together are more rather
than less likely to be divorced.
Now that might be.
That might have nothing to do with the
actual act of living together.
It might be that people who are more
likely to get divorced or also those who
are more likely to merely live together.
But I don't think that's a great
solution for reasons I won't get to go
get into now.
And with regards to being shackled
together is that.
That's a complicated one.
And,
and I learned this,
at least in part from reading Carl Jung
and the idea there is that unless you've
really made a commitment to someone like
a lifetime commitment and that that's a
serious commitment,
one that you're not going to back out
of.
You're not going to take the
relationship with the seriousness that's
necessary to make it have the highest
possible quality and sustainability
across the course of your life.
And it's really important that it is of
that high quality and sustainability.
Because the relationship,
especially when it starts to produce
children,
is a.
A machine.
Let's say a machine that you jointly
operate that adds immensely to the
quality of your life and the depth of
your life.
I mean you.
You have the rope and strand of your
life and your partner has the strands in
the rope of his or her life.
And then those are tied together to make
a stronger rope.
And then that unites you across time.
And then you undertake massive
adventures together.
And some of that is the establishment of
a household and the establishment of
joint careers and the maintenance of
each other's mental and physical health
and the maintenance of a high quality
sexual life and all of that very,
very challenging to do all of that.
And then the joint production and,
and care of children,
which,
which sets you up properly for the last
half of your life.
So like,
I'm 55 now,
you know,
and um,
both my kids just got engaged in the
last month,
so that's pretty bloody amazing.
And they're both setting up households
and um,
and there are stepping into adulthood
and I'm fortunate enough to have them in
the city that I live in.
So Hooray for me,
that's so bloody a fortunate that I can
hardly believe it.
I mean,
we've helped them out and tried to make
it,
um,
what would you say to make the
possibility of their living here be
something that's viable?
But I'm absolutely thrilled that they're
going to be around and I'm looking
forward immensely to having
grandchildren and like,
what else are you going to do when
you're 55?
You know,
when you're going to be 55,
it's going to,
I already have 40 more years,
like what am I going to do with those
years?
Well,
so I have a good marriage.
Thank God for that.
And that's partly due to the outstanding
moral quality of my life,
my wife,
who I'm also extraordinarily attracted
to.
And uh,
you know,
we've built a life together and we've
had kids together and we're happy with
our kids and we had plenty of,
of struggle with our kids because one of
our children,
my daughter had serious,
serious health problems,
which she seems to have managed to
resolve partly as a consequence of our
own brilliance.
Um,
but you know,
we've set ourselves up now so that our
children are respectable and mature
young adults.
So thank God for that.
And they've got partners who we both
really like and they're gonna have
children and well,
Hooray.
You know,
that means that this next part of my
life is going to be something that I can
advance into with a,
with a fair bit of hope and,
and,
and excitement.
And the idea of having little kids
around again is thrilling because I
really liked little kids.
They're really,
really fun.
And so there's the shackled together is
more like it's a,
it's,
it's such a.
I may have even said that,
but it's such a cynical way of looking
at it.
It's more like what you've produced is
an unbreakable bond between two beings
and that that makes both of them,
both of them better in every way.
If it's based on if it's a relationship
that's based on trust and genuine
communication at a very difficult thing
to attain because you have to be willing
to tell the truth.
And the truth is generally a horrible
thing.
You know?
I mean,
it's easy to tell truth when everyone
wants to hear what you have to say,
but it's very difficult to tell the
truth when no one wants to hear it.
Least of all yourself.
And so marriage gets a very bad rap in
our culture and Sodas,
child rearing.
And I think that's absolute catastrophe
because really being in a longterm
relationship,
a marriage,
let's say,
and having children,
that's two thirds of your life,
even if you're a highly career oriented
person that's two thirds of your life
and I'm a highly career oriented person
and my family has been unbelievably
important to me and has also been
something that's enabled me to be a very
effective in my career.
Because my house has been a sanctuary
for me and thank God for that.
Especially over on many times in my
life,
but especially over the last year.
So you should.
You should get to know someone long
enough to know that you too can now go
tell the truth with each other.
Communicate and negotiate.
Because the most important part of a
relationship is the fact that you can
tell each other the truth and negotiate.